we have a CBS News investigation into an
unprecedented review underway in
Maryland right now of 100 cases of
people who died in police custody all of
these deaths happened during the tenure
of former State medical examiner Dr
David Fowler his testimony in the George
Floyd murder case last year led to the
review Chief investigative correspondent
Jim Axelrod is with us now with more on
the story that the interview that we saw
with a woman that you talked to was
certainly a tease for this piece
powerful gift how it was as chief
medical examiner for the state of
Maryland Dr David Fowler oversaw more
than 1300 cases of deaths in custody his
record is now being called into question
following his testimony as a witness for
the defense in the trial last year of
the Minneapolis Police Officer convicted
of murdering George Floyd a warning some
of the footage of George Floyd's final
encounter with police is difficult to
watch
the honor the defense calls Dr David
Fowler when medical examiner David
Fowler took the stand in 2021 as a
defense expert for Derek Chauvin the cop
convicted of murdering George Floyd
Tawanda Jones was watching the trial
from her home in Baltimore I wanted to
knock my TV off the wall
this man that I've been telling y'all
about you put him up to be an expert
witness are you serious this is one of
those cases where you have so many
conflicting different manners Dr Fowler
saw what few others did I would fall
back to undetermined he argued that a
combination of factors made it
impossible to determine the true cause
of Floyd's death Dr Fowler's position
conflicted with the clear video evidence
find the defendant guilty and the jury's
verdict I was disgusted Jones was
disgusted because Dr Fowler was the
chief medical examiner for the state of
Maryland who signed off on the ruling
that the manner of death could not be
determined in another case in 2013 the
death of her own Brother Tyrone West I
instantly died with my brother on July
the 18th West was pulled over by police
in Baltimore nearly a decade ago he
struggled with the cops was cuffed and
died they just said that my brother had
some type of health issue and died in
police restraint that was their words
and we're like what health issue like
what are you talking about what do you
think was going on they were covering up
but Tawanda Jones wasn't the only one
outraged by Dr Fowler's testimony to
have that type of analysis on the stand
I was appalled Dr Roger Mitchell spent
seven years as the chief medical
examiner in Washington D.C I knew I had
to do something at that point Dr
Mitchell wrote this letter calling for
an immediate review of every death in
custody during Dr Fowler's tenure in
Maryland
1300 cases over 17 years in the work
that I've done throughout the country
there is a culture of deciding when
there is an altercation with law
enforcement Their Manners of death are
called accidents and undetermined how
does that change the potential
likelihood of a prosecution of a law
enforcement officer for the death of
somebody in custody I think it's a big
issue many prosecutors won't take a case
to prosecution if it's determined as an
accident or an undetermined more than
400 other medical professionals signed
on to Mitchell's letter calling for a
review when you get a letter from 400
experts say saying something's wrong
there's a pretty good chance that they
have something that you should take a
hard look at Maryland attorney general
Brian frosh has zeroed in on about a
hundred cases of individuals in custody
who were physically restrained and then
died with Dr Fowler's office then ruling
the cause as undetermined it was the
undetermined
that we were most interested in but more
importantly we want to see is there a
routine that is wrong would it be your
expectation that this review could lead
to criminal charges if they were
warranted well if they were warranted I
would hope that it would the hundred
cases under review are being kept secret
but Tawanda Jones refuses to believe her
brother's case could be forgotten what
are you going to do if your brother's
case is not among the hundred plus being
reviewed oh I know it is I know it is
but in a case that is not I'm going to
keep on fighting like I've been fighting
we wrote to and called Dr Fowler several
times he did not respond however earlier
he had said in a statement that he's
confident his office quote met or
exceeded Professional Standards so we're
hearing that they're reviewing 100 cases
yeah
what it's going to come next I was I'm
still stuck by her last comment about
her brother's case do you think do we
know of her brother's case is part of it
and what does come well first things
first so the AG we just heard from
leaves office January 3rd the incoming
attorney general a man named Anthony
Brown hasn't committed yet to whether or
not this process will continue he hasn't
said it won't he hasn't given any
indication but we have to wait until
January 3rd to see if the next Attorney
General will continue this it's a long
and complex process is Fowler still in
business so to speak well I mean he is
not the medical examiner but he is
offering defense testimony in cases as
you saw he did in the Chauvin case but
if the new guy comes in Jim and decides
he doesn't want to review it is that the
end of it yeah but he hasn't given any
indication and and I will say it's a
process that could take I mean we're
talking weeks months years it's not
going to be days right uh but we will be
staying on this story too important to
to yes Jim Axelrod thank you thank you